so Trev um you were seeing you broke up
with your girlfriend the one that you
were last time you were on right she
broke up with me why
life like well how did that conversation
go though
oh dude I cried cried hard
at night at a park dude I did a spot at
the Laugh Factory it was a great set I
had so much fun and she's like meet me
here and NBA we're already on Rocky
terms and she was living up she was
living out at a friend's house for like
the last month because we lived together
at the time and the spot was running
late and I was like I'll be there at
nine and then I'm like leaving the Laugh
Factory get a text at like nine o'clock
sharp she's like I'm here and I'm like
[__] I get there right as I get there
it's like this isn't working
X Y and Z wow there's people walking by
bawling my eyes out oh
no is that how people are supposed to
break up like in person face to face no
you don't think so I think so I think so
I don't like confrontation so I just do
it through text okay but that was a real
relationship
right it's
a breakup like
like I don't think there's a right or
wrong my friend got broken up with over
FaceTime that feels pretty pretty 2022
version right yeah I mean that's pretty
good yeah what's the worst like a voice
memo
I've done that before
yeah but that's just a hookup no
you're not serious yeah oh yeah it was a
situationship yeah but so and then when
you you cried how long did you cry
wow
that was my first like first love I got
my [__] shattered I was crying on the
floor
was it your fault though
I think yeah I'd say so
right because you're you know here's the
deal dude all right
our lifestyles you have to get adjusted
to it and some people can't and I will
say she she gave so much she gave me so
many chances and and it was like very
patient with me through the whole
process of like touring and doing all
this stuff so we're still in good terms
today like yeah let me join custody of a
cat oh that's great yeah yeah but yeah
it's it's you know
I've you know I've been on some days I
go you perform every night
once they say that you know it's like oh
it's not gonna work right already it's
not gonna work I had to really adjust
because I I went a little too far though
when we first started dating and I just
really wanted to spend time with him and
he wouldn't go to bed till 6 7 A.M so I
would stay up with him until six seven
a.m so that we would hang out and we
would like gallivant around Koreatown at
like 4 a.m and that's when we like
really connected but I knew that I was
like this is costly to my mental health
I'm sure but I was just so desperate to
make sure we had time together we
working like uh in the mornings at that
point or like um so when we first met
um I was
um still in nursing school right yep
yeah oh yeah those are wild hours as
well but I think like it is also like
insane to be like you're doing two shows
on a Monday like take a night off and
you're like nah I'm good like it's just
like it it's a weird thing to throw on
to somebody because other everyone else
they've always did is like they just get
off work at five and they're just like
ready to just make pancake eggs yeah I
mean in many ways
um
stand up in our business feels like a
relationship as well no of course yeah
yeah because you're investing time in it
it's so important and I don't know if
it's an addiction I don't know what it
is but it's like we I just I in fact I
think it is if I'm not doing it I'm
feeling I'm living left out I feel like
I'm not competing I feel like I'm you
know I mean I like have to be doing
something the nights were like we when
we were dating and like if she's like oh
let's take a let's do a date night
Thursday I'd be great but you go to bed
at like 10. I just sitting there at 10
knowing people are doing spots and I'm
just itching I'm trying to like fall
asleep in bed I'm like I gotta get up I
gotta edit I gotta do something like I
don't like being still I'm always trying
to do something that's what I love about
Sam it's like the daytime of focus on
videos and then at night time I'm doing
stand-ups so I'm always kind of doing
something for both but like for me to
take a day off it's I don't I'm just
sitting I'm like this is dumb yeah yeah
I think that's probably what we
struggled with too because if it didn't
involve work travel was not an option
for him so it was just like I will do
this with you you we can go there but
only if I have like dates there that you
know so we would have to yeah we're
going to Hawaii because I'm working in
Hawaii like on a show whatever I'm gonna
go out there a lot of that yeah yeah but
but we know we did we went to Hawaii
without with that
um that was one of the best ones that
was one of the best ones we've been to
Tulum without that and then the
Philippines Philippines without that so
we did something eventually I put my
foot down and I was like look we can't
keep doing it yeah you do it and it is
fun but like day three I'm itching I'm
in Tulum being like give me a [__]
mic and a goddamn camcorder I know I
know what is the hype on Tulum every hot
girl in America has been there
the Mexican Riviera is